thank you so much for for having me here
today I'm thrilled to share a bit of my
process behind making something I call
the cell tron annual report this is a
project I've been doing for about seven
years now and I'm a graphic designer by
trade and one of the things graphic
designers need is content and so you
know in with a desire to tell my own
stories I found through a process of
elimination that the best story I had
access to was my own story and so what I
started doing was tracking the minutiae
of my life and trying to figure out how
to turn this into something that would
describe the the patterns and nuances of
my day-to-day existence so here you can
see a spread from the first printed
edition this is the 2006 felcher on
annual report on the left you can see my
travel habits these are the places that
I went how much time I spent in
Manhattan versus Brooklyn versus some of
the other lesser visited boroughs on the
right you can see music and some of the
different data sources coming in are
from last.fm they're from iTunes and
then from manually collected things so
as I look back on this process of
collecting this data I can identify
three different processes that went into
this one of these is archaeology so this
is sort of the process of looking back
into old data or an old corpus and
extracting useful information from it
and this is something that I've done in
the initial annual report so this was in
2005 when I wasn't tracking for any
purpose I was just able to look into
records that I'd naturally been keeping
and I was able to extract
these different stories so in this case
this is a story about my photography and
by looking at the set of photos I took
over the year I could attach location to
them I could attach topics and I could
provide this histogram that says which
countries are more interesting or that I
took 1% of my photos have my cat in them
skip ahead to 2010 this is an annual
report that I made about my father's
life after he passed away and so again
this is an archeology I'm working only
with the data that I have at my disposal
and so I'm going through it and trying
to organize it trying to give it
metadata in ways that I can identify
patterns about my father's life this is
the corpus of material that I had to
draw on so we have about 3,000 slides 50
years of passports postcards 30 years of
calendars and what I did was I digitized
all of it
so all of his calendars I put into
spreadsheets and then I started tagging
them so that I could make associations
between them and derive patterns his
passports this was a process of
identifying all the location and time
stamps that go along with it to try and
make this map of all the places that he
went in the course of his life and of
trying to decipher these stamps some of
them are like CAPTCHAs some of them are
in different languages thankfully we
have tools these days that allow us to
to make sense of these things some
primary documents like his birth
certificate and he was very helpful as
well and he left behind the lists of
where he lived and who he'd worked for
so these came in handy and actually
became some somewhat of the backbone of
of this process I even came to embrace
receipts so you know while most of us
see zis is junk this is something that
I've come to identify as this amazing
sort of time and location stamped sheet
of paper so you can go back to these and
see where someone was in 1989 and then
postcards were another great source of
telling me where he lived over the
course of his lifetime
that's a family tree and then I went
through the process of identifying all
his photos trying to give them locations
trying to identify people who are in
them so I could tell you things like
what his favorite waterfall was this was
iguazu based on the number of photos
that he took a bit and finally this this
will be recognizable to most people in
the room but for me this was really the
crux of the project was that I found
this old EKG of his in a desk drawer
and so having my father's heart be
preserved and then being able to
reproduce it in a quantification of his
life was this great really moving record
of his life and talked to the greater
sense of the project as well so here you
can see his life as quantified and this
was sort of a four or five week struggle
to bring all this information to life to
make it not just a severe accounting of
what he'd done but to actually try and
extract his personality from it so on a
base level I'm trying to describe all
the places is he all the places he
visited but I'm also trying to pull out
little pieces of the patterns that
described his life like who were his
favorite lunch partners or where were
his favorite places to go and here you
can see some details so looking at his
calendars I can identify this meta trend
in the 80s where he retired which is the
white line declining in the top left
corner and other lines like travel and
time with kids were on the rise so this
is strictly done from categorizing his
calendars and looking at his activities
and this is another interesting thing
identified that he he had a beard for
six months from April to September of
1970 and this is just by looking at the
photos that I have of him and then this
is a piece of the atlas that I made that
describes all the different places that
he traveled and I have some thoughts on
archaeology I think it's a great
approach but it's also rooted in the
source material so
you're stuck with what you're working
with and with my father I was looking to
have a really rich corpus of material
and there's typically incompleteness but
you just have to embrace that and so
this is the other this is another
process I've been very good at and it's
what I consider data hoarding and this
is what happens when you identify data
streams and you don't want to let go of
them like receipts so the bulk of my
reports have been based on data hoarding
this is 2006 where I started collecting
expressly for the purposes of making
this document I explored places I ate
and drank and here you can see all the
different
it's a taxonomy of all the different
animals I ate in 2006 I don't think it's
a scientific taxonomy but in 2007 I took
the level further so driven by my
curiosity I tried to answer questions
like how many lethal doses of caffeine
did I drink over the course of the year
and which roads did I walk down in New
York City so the hoard the hoarding
continued so 6.8 lethal doses and that's
how many that's how many milligrams of
caffeine I estimated entering in 2008 I
became fascinated with how far I
traveled over the course of the year so
I adopted a pedometer I started keeping
track of both real world mileage and in
Grand Theft Auto 4 I could get
helicopter mileage and motorcycle
mileage so I incorporated that but the
the idea here was to come up with one
number that could be a sort of totemic
number for the year and this is part of
that number thirty-eight thousand five
hundred I think in 24 was the number of
miles that I'd traveled over the course
of the year and I felt like this would
encapsulate both six days when I don't
travel very far and the vacation days
where I travel thousands of miles and
finally this is the the 2010-2011
biennial report this is a report in
which I tried to track every single
place that I went over the course of the
year and I also tried to tackle who I
was with so that I could say with my
girlfriend these are the places that we
like to go with my best friend this is
where
go when I'm in New York these are my
habits when it melts who are these are
my other habits and you can see these
all sort of overlaid in this document
where blue represent 2010 and the
magenta represents 2011 and then they're
overlaid in different different manners
with pie charts evaluating the different
behaviors and and here's a detail so
this is with my girlfriend you can see
in the left that's California and on the
right hand side that's New York City so
there's a yarn connecting all these
places and you can see from the purple
ones where the overlap occurs which were
the places that we went to over both
years so this is one of the downsides of
hoarding this is what your calendar
comes to look like when you're trying to
track everything you eat and drink
everywhere you go and everyone you're
with so it's kind of color-coded and I
did this for two years and then I let it
go so these are my thoughts on hoarding
you know you can you can achieve a high
degree of completeness with this but the
costs are high and in trying to create
these documents I'm trying to come up
with methodologies that don't interfere
in the life I'm trying to record so I
constantly get the question like how
much do you track how much time you
spend tracking which for me is a sort of
recursive problem and I don't want to
think about it
but I'm always I don't even do any
analysis until the end of the year I
want to tell you this all up and then
look back on the behavior and there are
certain problems that I just can't get
at these are sort of the intractable set
and these have driven some of the other
experiments that I've done so I feel
like tracking food is a very complicated
problem that no one has really cracked
reading is something that should be
quite easy but we do it on many devices
we do it with paper we do it with eing
devices and that's not unlocked mood is
something I feel like I'm very bad at
self reporting TV I find it's kind of
interesting you must be new when the box
was on you don't even know if you're
paying attention to it in conversations
another thing that
fascinates me whether I could track all
the conversations I have so these things
I consider imprecise or or too tough to
capture but I'm always trying to push my
approach to be able to embrace these
things and this brings me to the third
approach that I started tinkering with
which is sampling so trying to just use
these discrete measurements to make
sense of behaviors I find really
complicated this is the basis of my 2009
and your report I really wanted to
figure out what my mood was I had a
couple questions how happy was I and am
i an introvert or an extrovert so if I
felt like I've had a meaningful
encounter with you this is sort of
legalese that I set up around it if we
had a meaningful encounter then you
would receive one of these cards from me
and it invited you to visit a URL where
you would answer a survey and I made
these very rigid and letterpress so that
you wouldn't throw it away
this would haunt you and when you had
time you would you would go to this
survey and answer all these different
questions so the better activities and
my mood and what we talked about and and
this is what the report wound up looking
like it incorporates some of the quotes
from it but I had to quantify all this
information that was all just
unstructured data that came in so here's
a list of all the different moods I was
described as having you will see that
there's probably not an index that would
include chopstick or californian so I
asked Mechanical Turk to rate all these
words on these axes from happy to sad or
introverted to extroverted and I was I
was able to come up with an indices for
this so I can tell you now that
chopsticks is slightly positive at the
point eight on this scale californian is
also actually more neutral it's closer
to zero it's zero point four but things
like buzzy just these really esoteric
terms I was able to make sense of and I
could tell you that my average mood for
that year was swell which is in in my
index is seventy three point nine
percent happy and I also found out that
I'm an Ambo
which is somewhere in between
introverted and extroverted and so
finally I talk about embracing sampling
so for this year I've had this app
developed which is called reporter it
was built for me and what reporter does
is it buzzes approximately every 90
minutes it's not on a schedule so I
can't game the system and it asked me
what I'm doing and also takes all these
background readings so you can see the
row of sensors above the top it's
getting location it's getting time it's
getting the weather from an API it gets
the ambient audio and then some stuff
that's running on the phone like
connectivity and what apps are in the
stack and how many photos I've taken
since the last time it goes off and and
then I take a survey so now I'm giving
context to all these ambient readings so
I'm telling it where I am and what I'm
doing I tell it what I'm wearing and
this solves a couple of questions for me
so I also have the eating and drinking
in there but in terms of tackling a
couple of intractable questions one of
them is what tools are you using which
to try and do this with perfect accuracy
would be basically impossible but if
you're just asked in this sampled method
you can start to make sense of it and
also social networks so whereas before
when I tried to track who I was with I
just had a selected set of people and I
knew that when I was with my girlfriend
I was going to track when um when she
was around and when she wasn't around
versus this I can now keep track of the
guy who sits behind me at work who I
don't socialize with but maybe I spend
more time with him than my girlfriend so
I'm really interested in how these
results will knit out and and figuring
out which networks are connected to to
which and how and so here are my
thoughts on sampling that there is value
in this in completeness and I can gain
insight here and I also hope that having
about 4,000 records at the end of the
year will will be enough for some
interesting results thank you very much
you